It's far into the night, but sleep won't come.
You turn over.
Perhaps a different position will quieten
the mind.
Or maybe the other side was better after all.
Not sleeping feels like a disaster.
But in smaller doses, insomnia does not need
a cure.
It's there for a reason; it's doing work for
us.
- and we should learn to let it take its course.
Crucial things we need to think about are
seeking their chance to bubble into consciousness.
This insomnia is a form of revenge for all
the many ideas we pushed away, or could not
entertain in the day - but that matter intensely
to our self-understanding and development.
We have been busy for too long; we have been
running on empty.
But at night, we can return to a bigger duty:
to ourselves.
What we think about now would sound weird
to so many people - my partner, my mother,
my friend, my boss, my child.
These people need us to be a certain way.
We don't want to let them down. But their
expectations choke off important aspects of
who we are.
Yet now, it is just us and the universe
- and for a time, we can take on a little
of its boundlessness.
With a pad of paper and a pen, and a little
bedsight light on, we can dare to investigate
the big questions that we normally push away
and that manifest themselves just as background anxieties.
We start to untangle our knotted feelings
and ideas.
Things will have to change.
There are exciting plans afoot too.
Perhaps we can chuck it
in, and start anew; perhaps it’s time for
that idea we've had for so long.
Night offers us safety from the scepticism
of sensible others.
It allows us time to get ourselves together.
We want to arrive, eventually, at a feasible,
defensible strategy.
But we can start with thoughts, schemes that
look unimpressive, weird and possibly absurd.
Night is a friend to the slow process of growth
that every ambitious project demands:
it provides us with the cover to grow into
our more complete selves.
We shouldn't be in such a rush to escape it.